des républicains depuis
qu'elle a osé s'en prendre
à Donald Trump. En route vers
le bureau de vote, elle met
et menacée, dit-elle.
Tous ceux qui croient
à la liberté doivent mettre
leurs valeurs au-dessus deststst
lorsque les partisans
de Donald Trump envahissaient
le Capitole, le 6 janvier,
car ils nelelelelelelelelelelel.
C'est la rupture.
"Donald Trump a fa l le choix
de violer le serment qu'il a
prêté en tant que président."
en accusation, co-préside
la commissiod'd'enquête
du 6 janvier. Elle met alors en
péril son siège de représentante
Le risque en vaut la chandelle,
selon elle. Après tout,
il
du pays. Un sentiment que
p partagent pas beaucoup
d'électeurs républicains
à la défense de leur idole.
"Elle est en train d'endommager
le pays, dit-il.
Il y a trop derarame."
coqueluche des républicains
et surtout de Dona T Trump.
Elle est devenue son porte-voix
au Wyoming.
Et en 2016, elle était pourtant
une des plus ferventes
Aujourd'hui elle est sa rivale,
et va mpmporter la mise.
"Donald
car il ment à ses électeurs.
En 246nsns d'histoire,
il est la plus grande menace
à notre républie.e."
Peu importe les avertissements,
Trump demeure très populaire
remporté avec 70% des voix
en 2020.
"Nous nous battons contre
le mal", dit Adam Kinzinger,
qui ne se représentera pas
aux primil a reçu des menaces dt
pour s'être opposé
à Donald Trump.s s s s s s s s ,
c'est le début d'une longue
bataille, dit-elle. Nous faisons
face à des temps difficiles.